Film Courage: What do you say to screenwriters
that are afraid someone will steal either
their idea or their finished script?
Lee Jessup: This is really so unsexy.
Get over it!
There really is nothing for the industry to
gain from stealing work.
If you’re a brand new writer and you wrote
something that is the greatest idea ever,
the industry is much better off (you’re
not a WGA member) buying that script from
me for $25,000, $30,000, maybe $50,000 and
doing whatever they want with it versus potentially
getting tied up in lawsuits.
It really doesn’t pay anybody to steal work
in this industry.
You can’t come at the industry from a place
of mistrust.
You can’t come at agents and managers saying
“Well, I’ll send you my work but I’m
really nervous because I’ve heard about
how scripts get stolen” because then you’re
coming at it from a place of “I” automatically
do not trust you [i.e., The Industry].
I’m the writer.
You’re going to victimize me.
Nobody wants to work with that.
Nobody wants to deal with that.
The reality is when Bridesmaids came out,
I can’t tell you how many writers came to
me and said “Oh my God!
I wrote that exact same script.”
There are ideas that are zietgeistsy.
There are ideas that are in the moment and
those ideas tend to manifest in many different
places.
But it really does not serve you in any way
to think that the industry will steal your
work.
Your job with your script that you have (if
you’re writing outside of the industry and
in all likelihood if you have a feature script),
the job of that feature script is to get you
an agent, to get you a manager.
That is it’s job.
It likely won’t sell as it is to the industry.
We are in this industry in 2016, we are likely
to sell less than a hundred specs.
That is not a big number.
If you’re aiming for that bullseye, that
is a narrow, narrow, narrow bullseye.
You want to use that script to get you an
agent, to get you a manager, to introduce
you to the industry, to get on the prestige
list, that’s what you want this script to
do for you.
In order to do that you have to expose the
work.
Get over any idea that somebody will steal
your script because that’s just not going
to happen.
And on the rare, rare, rare occasions that
it has, the writer usually got their own success
in their own way.
Film Courage: Well, let’s continue with
the topic of mistrust.
On your screenwriting blog for your website
LeeJessup.com you have a post entitled ‘Screenwriters
Leave Your Mistrust at the Door.”
Lee Jessup: Yes.
Film Courage: I know some of us are way
more trusting than others.
Some of us are maybe more on the naïve scale.
You talked about a lot of things that many
people would be afraid of like They Want Me
to Sign a Release Form?
I mean, that is scary.
That’s a little scary.
Or I think we’re touching on the same thing
as before “Somebody Has the Same Concept
of Mine.
Somebody Stole My Idea.”
“Wouldn’t They Rather Cheat Me Than Pay
Me?”
So...how do you work with someone who is already
coming in with those set of fears and make
them so they are a little more workable, but
not naïve and not a doormat?
Lee Jessup: I always tell my writers that
I’m the safe space so you can let out all
of your neuroses and I’ll put you in your
place.
I actually wrote that particular blog post
after a writer of mine had finished a script.
The script had been entered into one contest,
hadn’t placed and another script with eerie
similarities sold.
Eerie, eerie, eerie similarities.
And the writer came to me and said “What
Am I To Make of This?”
And we had to kind of sit back and say “O.K.
here is where the script was.
Here is the writer who just sold a script.
There is no... as much as I understand there
are eerie similarities, let’s talk through
what the probability would be of this writer,
an established writer with a summer blockbuster
would have of stealing your script.
Let’s talk through it.
I always tell me writers “I’m a Safe Space.
We Need to Talk About It.”
But...at some point a writer either wises
up or not.
I work with a writer that I no longer work
with who refused to pitch any ideas, talk
log lines, or anything as such in a public
environment.
So in a coffee shop, in a bar, which is where
a lot of industry meetings take place mind
you, the writer refused to do it because somebody
would listen and somebody would steal this
idea and it became uncomfortable.
At some point I had to say to the writer “Listen,
you’re going to have managers meeting with
you.”
There was a manager who wanted to meet with
that writer in a coffee shop.
So the manager is going to ask you “What
else do you have?”
What are you going to say?
“I can’t tell you here.
I’ll send you an email.”
It doesn’t work that way.
Even if you have it innately, you have to
set it aside.
You have to.
Because this industry works the way that it
does with the idea of trust and respecting
the creative mind, the creative brain, the
originator of content.
If you originated a great idea, a great script,
a great story, why would would I steal it
from you?
Why wouldn’t I just take the thing that
is already done and do something with it?
Wouldn’t that make more sense for me?
If I’m a producer, an executive, why would
I steal it, get somebody else to write it,
potentially for more money because they are
already well known, either they executed well
or they don’t . Maybe they don’t.
Or somebody else does the same thing to you
before my script is done, why wouldn’t I
just pick it up from you, the creator of content
who came up with this great concept, what
incentive do I (an executive) have to steal
it from you?
And that is what a lot of writers have to
(despite how frustrating it can get) look
at.
And that’s ultimately what that writer and
myself have to look at when a script with
eerie similarities to this individual’s
sold.
There was no way for the manager who sold
that script to get that script.
There was no way that an industry executive
had read that script.
It has been submitted to one place, three
months before.
There was just no reality in which the script
was stolen or rewritten.
What the writer had to acknowledge was that
ultimately if I’m the manager behind the
script sale and let’s assume I’ve got
a completed script that is great which I think
I can sell and I have this writer who just
had a box office success, what is my best
way of making the most money?
My best way of making the most money is getting
the one script that is ready to sell and selling
it and booking my writer who just had a big
box-office success on a writing assignment
and making more money.
Why limit the ways in which I’m making money
by having the writer then take the script
and try to make money off of it rather than
monetize both?
So those are the equations that writers have
to look at.
Is it really in the industry’s best interest
to steal content?
I really don’t find that it is.
QUESTION TO THE VIEWERS: Do you agree?
What is your stance on Hollywood stealing
ideas?